[Music]
everybody is Charlie we have huge news
Marvel confirmed that they're developing
an Avengers force spin-off for the
Winter Soldier character and they
announced some more details about the
other Avengers characters that are
getting spin-offs so we got to break it
down there were also a bunch of you
requesting I do a giveaway for Red Dead
Redemption so we'll make the giveaway
for that all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a Marvel
related comment on the video so I know
you all want to know about the story
when is it gonna drop which characters
is going to involve who the villains
going to be so important details just
like the Loki series The Scarlet Witch
series this will be Sebastian Stan's
character after the events of Avengers 4
and Anthony Mackey's Falcon character
will co-star so it'll be the two of them
but obviously Winter Soldier gets top
billing you can understand why they
would probably choose to put those two
characters together just because they
serve as a great action duo and a great
comedic duo at the same time they just
have great joke chemistry we'll call
that soft confirmation that rocket never
gets that arm they did confirm it's
going to be six to eight episodes I
think they just haven't quite decided
exactly how the story is gonna play out
so they don't know how long the episodes
are gonna be if it'll be like normal 42
minute episodes or if it'll be a full 60
minutes or it'll be like the last couple
of seasons of Game of Thrones in their
feature-length episodes all that means
is is that they're longer than 60
minutes so just expect them to be bigger
episodes because they're gonna be on the
streaming service there'll be no add
breaks in the middle of it I know
there's a lot of questions about pricing
and just physically how you're gonna be
able to watch the episodes so I'll
address that at the end of the video the
other really big news that was buried in
this Winter Soldier announcement was
that they confirmed Paul Bettany's
vision character will be a really big
part of scarlet witch's spin-off which I
think we all were kind of hoping but
it's always hard to tell because there's
so much special effects involved in just
bringing his character to screen even if
he's not flying around or phasing
through objects all the time are using
his crazy powers
but the good thing about this is it when
they first started announcing these
series like the Loki series they said
that they were planning on spending Game
of Thrones level money on all these
which is why they're only doing six to
eight episodes Disney has almost
infinite amounts of money it makes sense
that if they were going with their ælis
characters and actors they would want to
spend that aliased level of money and
because they're only doing a small
number of episodes they can shoot those
do all the special effects and then
release the episodes later in the year
it's not like network TV where they're
finishing an episode once every eight
days so you can do a little bit of
special effects but every once in a
while it winds up looking like ps2
graphics you'll be able to watch an
episode with like Winter Soldier or
vision flying around and it will look
very similar if not exactly the same as
it would be if you were seeing them
flying around in a movie one of the good
things about Marvel Studios is as they
pioneer a lot of special effects for
their big movies like the big Titan
battle if you haven't seen any of the
behind the scenes for that they started
planning that day one it was literally
the first shot that they did and they
released that teaser with Robert Downey
jr. Chris Pratt and Tom Holland on set
saying hello welcome to Avengers we just
started shooting that's how long it took
them to finish the special effects for
that but within the next four to five
years or so it'll be a lot easier to do
stuff like that on a TV level budget
here's a couple big details though when
you read between the lines Winter
Soldier will probably never get a
spin-off movie of his own because Kevin
Feige said the whole reason for doing
the spin-off series were for characters
that weren't going to get their own solo
movies during phase 4 or phase 5
so no Winter Soldier solo movie no
Anthony Mackie Falcon solo movie and
neither one of them is probably going to
be taking the mantle of Captain America
because that's like a really big movie
moment you don't do that on a TV series
but it's not really a big surprise that
they're not just immediately passing the
mantle of Captain America regardless of
what happens to Chris Evans like even if
he retires they could still pass the
mantle to another character there have
been so many people to be Captain
America in the comics that there are a
number of
other choices you can kind of see their
thought process to their like okay we're
just gonna put his shield over on the
shelf and wait till Chris Evans wants to
come back and cameo in a far-distant
Avengers movie and then we can always
pass the mantle there's no rush to have
another Captain America running around
on screen if it's not going to be Chris
Evans because you have all these new
characters to introduce in if you're
gonna have somebody that's called
captain on the Avengers Carol Danvers is
coming in so she'll be the new cap
quote-unquote even though I really hope
that they don't call her that
I'm sure Falcon or spider-man or one of
the other characters will coin some
nickname for her but for now I'm just
thinking of her as Carol Danvers they
haven't said a whole lot about what the
plot is gonna be other than obviously
it's picking up in the wake of Avengers
4 so for the most part I'm just assuming
they're picking up where Captain
America's Secret Avengers left off
between the events of Civil War and
Avengers infinity war they released a
prequel comic book that told some of
that story it was the Avengers version
of the spider-man homecoming plot where
vulture and the Tinker were creating a
black market for alien weapons in tech
remember how Ironman said that that was
below the Avengers pay grade when
Spiderman told him about it you can see
that he wanted spider-man to shut up and
just chill out for a minute but also the
Russos confirms some details about what
was happening with Iron Man and Captain
America after the events of Civil War so
part of the reason why Ironman says
below Avengers pay grade is is because
he knew about caps Secret Avengers
running around the globe tearing down
alien arms trade there was actually a
moment during infinity war where you see
the cap flip phone there's an outgoing
call on there to implying that Iron Man
at some point at least tried to call
Captain America even though they imply
that they haven't spoken since civil war
if they can get the actor to come back
easy slam dunk villain for that Winter
Soldier series would be Baron Zemo
setting up a masters of evil within the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that they can
sort of spill over into the other
spin-off series and maybe kick it into
the movies if it becomes a big enough
thing but as for vision Scarlet Witch TV
series just because it's them together
it implies they'll be spending time
dealing with their really complicated
relationship from the comics delving
more into the nature of their powers and
because it's Scarlet Witch
really hoping that the villain winds up
being a magic bass villain with loose
ties to the Doctor Strange canon so that
they can spend some time developing her
chaos magic from the comics you've all
been asking about tying Scarlet Witch of
the MCU to whatever MCU magneto is going
to be like when he resurfaces they can
actually start setting that story up
during The Scarlet Witch solo series
like she learns the secret of her true
biological father that person just
happens to be magneto and they can deal
with it in a future x-men movie because
regardless of what they do with Scarlet
Witch in the MCU Elizabeth Olsen is a
very young person she can keep playing
that character for a long time so she
might not be in every single movie but
they can always bring her back for a
really big x-men movie or a really big
Avengers movie so probably announced a
couple more of these big spin-off series
they haven't said which other characters
are gonna get them they haven't said
anything more about a potential Hawkeye
series but right now I'm assuming that
they'll go into production and they'll
drop them in the order that they
announced them so that would mean that
the Loki TV series would be first then
they do the Scarlet Witch vision series
then they would do the Winter Soldier or
Falcon series Loki is the only one that
I'm expecting to be set during the past
just because they killed him during
infinity war so unless they're trying to
totally mislead us and he does come back
for real during Avengers 4 it'll have to
be set during the past right now it
sounds like they plan on releasing these
during different times of the year
staggered so that they have a steady
stream of new content coming to the
service so maybe Loki sometimes spring
2020 then during the summer they'll have
that Scarlet Witch vision series then a
little bit later in the year Falcon
Winter Soldier and then if you guys
didn't remember the Star Wars
Mandalorian series is gonna premiere at
the end of next year during the winter
so winter 2019 that Avengers 4 trailer
is coming later in November so hopefully
they'll announce some more details about
this other content around the same time
click here for my video on that leaked
trailer and click here for my Spider Man
far from home black costume video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]